okay here are the questions that people
wrote in congressman Ryan given how
Nancy Pelosi hasn't reformed as Speaker
so far do you regret your past
opposition to her question right now I
think I think she's done a magnificent
job handling Trump not just the Trump
dynamic but protecting the integrity of
article 1 of the Constitution I think
she's done a phenomenal job and I don't
regret it because we were able to over
the last couple years we moved a lot of
new people into leadership Hakeem
Jeffries Katherine Clark Ben ray Lujan
she's fighting well we just needed to
start getting some people in line and I
think we were able to do that but I
think it worked out best of both worlds
Neera does the Trump does the drum beat
by the Trump administration to go to war
with Iran remind you of the lead up to
the Iraq war oh yes of course given that
the architect is the same right John
John Bolton is mr. I want regime change
I think what's concerning this time
around is that Donald Trump has
completely out sourced what our Middle
East policy should be to Saudi Arabia
and Israel who also want to see regime
change in Iran and the scary thing is
that regime change rarely happens
without some bloodshed without military
involvement and we also now have an
election coming up in which he may think
it's a good way to distract the American
public right well he one good thing
about him winning he doesn't need to
that's the one silver lining in
[ __ ] everything up was that now
he's the big winner he doesn't have to
start a war Matt Lewis will you vote for
Trump in 2020 now will we vote for the
Democrat you know because if you don't
vote for the Democrat then just you're
just jerking off man but I'll tell you
what if you're gonna write in John
McCain he's dead he's not gonna be
President
so let's see someday they're gonna bring
him back um he's being I mean it's that
we only get two choices in this country
and if you if you if you think Trump is
all that bad then you vote for the dog
I'll tell you there's someone and I like
what I heard tonight but I you know this
Andrew yang fella yeah we have month we
have Mon I think coming up platform well
that's that's a secondary issue from a
second but I'm not in the yang gang yet
but I like I like what he has to say i D
I think he's appealing to some
interesting throw depend on the
Democrats who absolutely would you vote
for Biden no no no Donald Trump versus
Joe Biden and yeah you're gonna say
you're past what they've you live in I
live in Virginia okay so yeah I pro-life
you wouldn't vote so for me the life
issue is a very very important issue to
a life or death issue but then there's
also I can't vote for Trump because he's
a bad person and the attack of character
and integrity so but there's always one
choice that's better mature people
understand there's always one choice
that's you know people say if you don't
vote if you don't vote then you can't
[ __ ] and complain and I say just watch
me I'm gonna do it anyway
okay now that we know Michael Cohen
helped Jerry Falwell with blackmail
photos do you think Trump has something
on other clients like Sean Hannity well
let me know know if they even know this
story but yes Michael Cohen it came out
and Tom Arnold Tom Arnold yes that Tom
Arnold befriended Michael Cohen in this
recent period before Michael colon went
to jail which I think was today and only
like a month ago Michael Cohen said I
love this Trump not only is he probably
a blackmailer he lends out Michael Cohen
as a blackmailer and so Jerry Falwell Jr
is getting blackmailed by some guy we
don't know who ya with my Gracie photic
racy photographs truck Michael Cohen
comes in and says I took care of it
except I kept one picture so now he's
black so like
he's yeah and then it was very odd like
a month later Jerry Falwell Jr endorsed
you know the it's not just the blackmail
it it's blackmail bullying and the other
B is bribery because if you watch the
way that Trump actually gained bribery
is maybe a harsh word for this but when
Donald Trump was first running thinking
about running for the Republican
nomination the Trump Foundation started
making donations to groups
I think $50,000 to CPAC that was his
Britt big first foray so I don't think
that he probably has any sort of picnic
at pictures of Sean Hannity I just think
he's got multiple ways of coercion yeah
so okay
does the restructure does the
restrictive abortion legislation in Ohio
Georgia and Alabama concern you this is
for you but we can all yeah no
absolutely and we had a case just this
week where what is that eleven eleven
neat well it's super restrictive
criminal penalties for the doctor this
week an eleven year old girl was raped
got pregnant tragic tragic situation
obviously yeah and under Ohio law that
just went in to affect this woman this
young girl could not have an abortion
and so that's the ultimate of the
government being in the middle of that's
the law right now I know yes just yeah
just woman no effect if she can't who
can
I don't know if they would have to take
her out of state or how it would work
but that sounds like you know when
analyzing going out of state now for
receiving some kind of treatment and
with the six-week fetal heartbeat which
is it's actually not technically a heart
there it's just anyhow that's the
science behind it but that's why you
need should have doctors and medical
professionals involved in these
decisions but you I mean a woman can
miss her period not even know you can
miscarry and now you could be arrested
for that for your body's natural rhythms
can be used against you what do you
think about this your well look I mean
it's obviously a horrible situation I
think most mainstream conservatives I'll
allow for exceptions for say like the
case of rape for example and so you'd be
against this I would I as a pub as a
matter of public policy I would be
against this so there are places on your
pro-life yeah but there is something
that goes too far for you well yeah I
think is it no look you could you could
ask here's the problem that pro-lifers
have of course is like once you make the
argument that that life is precious and
that this is an unborn child then it
doesn't by that definition right if you
just sort of carry that logic forward
but politics is about we we live in a
fallen world we live in a messy world
and it's about making public policy
decisions right I think that's an
example where I think 99% of Pro lifers
would say in that instance that is an
exception well I mean you had the entire
Ohio legislature House and Senate and a
Republican governor passed this so I
mean that is not the majority of
Republicans they control the house I
think people forget I think sometimes I
think the Roe versus Wade ruling in 1973
said abortion is legal it did not
it said states right it passed it back
to the states I said we're not making it
illegal federally but it's really you're
making it impossible at the gate in
local level to actually make these
medical decisions absent any Supreme
Court ruling okay funny stuff thank you
very much I appreciate you coming and
helping us out
you